this is tamar hussein reading for
reviewer richard wakeling let's not be
around the bush back for blood is left
for dead 3 in all but name the
similarities between the original game
and this spiritual successor are endless
even after a 12 year gap yet it's their
overt differences that proved to be the
most interesting part of back for blood
it still maintains all of the familiar
hallmarks of left 4 dead only now these
new foundations are interspersed with
contemporary ideas befitting of the
modern era resulting in a game that
captures what you might expect from a
reanimated left for dead in the year
2021
back for blood's chaotic template might
be the most overt similarity between the
two games as you and up to three friends
are tasked with surviving the ravenous
zombie hordes as you desperately fight
from one safe room to another the
campaign is split into four acts with
each one containing a variable number of
chapters the first act is the longest
for instance coming in at 13 chapters
while the final act consists of a single
boss fight finishing the entire campaign
on the game's regular and easiest
difficulty will probably take you around
six to seven hours but back for blood
offers plenty of replayability when you
factor in the other two punishing
difficulty levels and the game's
inherent variety the ai game director
which makes on-the-fly decisions on
where and what enemies spawn returns
from left for dead and ensures that each
character is noticeably different on
repeat visits as it also manipulates
hazard placement weapon availability and
zombie frequency which differ with every
playthrough you're also faced with the
same kinds of objectives throughout the
campaign whether that means simply
making it to the next safe room alive
alerting the horde in order to remove an
obstacle and progress forward or
defending a location until you're able
to escape it's familiar territory if
you've ever played left for dead and
this works him back for blood's favor
when it begins to veer from that exact
formula during one chapter you find a
safe room almost immediately but instead
of escaping you have to locate and
rescue a group of survivors first there
are more interesting examples too
including a chapter that sees you
stumble upon a decimated police station
where the only way out is locked by a
hand scanner not only do you have to
find a dead guy's severed arm to unlock
it but whoever picks it up is forced to
wield the limp as a morbid weapon while
you mash your way back to the door
there's another chapter where you have
to plant explosives on the ship and
escape before it blows while one of back
for blood's best moments occurs in a bar
as you're tasked with creating a
distraction so another group of
survivors can slip away unnoticed as it
turns out zombies can't help but
gravitate towards the sound of let me
kill myself gravelly rasp emanating from
a tired old jukebox as motorhead's ace
of spades provides the energetic
soundtrack to the ballroom massacre not
every objective is quite as exciting
though there are a few too many
instances where you have to destroy
pulsating zombie nodes before being able
to progress and the final chapters in
three of the four acts are
disappointingly anticlimactic and
tedious fortunately caving in craniums
and filling zombies full of lead remains
enjoyable throughout your arsenal of
weapons consists of the usual assortment
of assault rifles smgs shotguns snipers
and a lethal collection of melee tours
the gunplay is more in line with modern
shooters than left for dead as you'll
spend most of your time aiming down
sights to pop headshots and focus fire
on the special infected's glowing weak
spots the weapons are punchy and zombies
react to your shots in satisfying ways
gradually coating everything in a thick
crimson layer of blood
there are other modern touches too
including colour-coded weapon rarities
because of course there are each of the
eight playable characters begins with a
specific primary and secondary weapon
but you'll acquire more firearms as you
loot abandoned houses and spend copper
to purchase new guns in the safe rooms
store you can also find and purchase
weapon attachments that will boost stats
like firepower and accuracy but these
don't carry over if you swap weapons
which feels oddly restrictive the most
notable new addition however is the
introduction of a deck building mechanic
as you complete chapters you'll earn
supply points that can be spent on
acquiring more cards in order to build a
custom deck of 15. the most basic cards
provide small boost to vital stats like
health and ammo capacity but you'll
eventually gain access to more elaborate
ones that have a tangible effect on the
moment-to-moment gameplay this might be
a card that turns your bash into a knife
essentially giving you a third weapon
store or a card with a team-wide effect
that provides everyone with a 30 damage
increase whenever someone is
incapacitated you can even build a deck
to suit a particular play style by
focusing on healing base cards to become
the team's de facto medic for instance
or boosting your health and using a card
that heals with each melee kill to
become the frontline tank meanwhile the
ai game director uses corrupted cards
during each chapter to really emphasize
back for blood's variety by challenging
you with additional obstacles one
corrupted card shrouds the environment
in a dense fog that makes it impossible
to see a few feet in front of your face
while another introduces flaming zombies
to the mix these hazards become more
devious on higher difficulty levels yet
it's tough to strategize and count as
specific threats with your own cards
when the corrupted ones are chosen at
random which does take away from the
system's dynamism somewhat this also
contributes to some glaring balancing
issues on every difficulty level unlike
left 4 dead which threw special infected
at you every now and then back for blood
strongest zombies come at you in an
incessant stream of tour boys hawkers
and reekers there's nothing particularly
special about these abominations when
they're almost ever present so fighting
each variation quickly becomes rope and
that's without mentioning they're mostly
one note attacks that simply pin you
into place the special infected in left
4 dead didn't do much more than this
either but they were infrequent and each
one felt unique music played a
significant part in this generating a
feeling of simmering dread every time
the witch's whaling theme would cut
through the silence or the tank
announced its terrifying arrival with a
thunderous orchestra back for blood
doesn't use musical cues probably
because it would be an auditory mess
with how many special infected appear at
one time
playing with friends papers over these
issues to some extent and this is
obviously where back for blood's co-op
excels if you don't have three fans to
play with the waiting times for
matchmaking aren't too long via
crossplay and the game's handy ping
system means you're able to communicate
fairly well without having to talk to
strangers the quality of your teammates
will inevitably vary which is a problem
when you can't vote to kick afk players
this is a puzzling omission especially
when back for blood actively punishes
you for playing solo while you have the
option to play through an entire
campaign with three bots doing so cuts
you off from earning all of the game's
rewards including both supply points and
trophies this means that you can't
unlock any cosmetic items or new cards
for your deck so you're forced to play
with other people to make any kind of
progress back for blood is meant to be
played cooperatively but punishing
people who want to play alone is
unnecessary particularly when it doesn't
have the tools to deal with players who
are wasting everybody else's time
outside of the campaign back for blood
also features a pvp swarm mode where
teams take turns playing as humans and
the special infected rather than
adopting the left 4 dead method of
making the campaign competitive swarm
locks you into a multiplayer arena where
whoever survives as the humans the
longest wins the round it's fine for a
few rounds mainly because playing as the
undead offers something different but
this isn't a mod you're likely to go
back to the campaign is back for blood's
main draw but you really need a group of
friends to enjoy it to the fullest as a
spiritual successor to left 4 dead it
takes almost all of the right boxes the
modern additions add to the game's
variety and ensure that each run is
unique while the moment-to-moment
gunplay is intense and incredibly
gratifying the overwhelming frequency of
the special infected and their
disappointing blindness is a downer and
the lack of some quality of life
features makes playing with strangers
more frustrating than it should be
especially when you're penalized for
playing alone the landscape of
co-operative shooters has changed a lot
in the past 12 years and back for blood
might not live up to the heights of left
4 dead at its peak nevertheless total
rock's return to the genre it created is
still excellent fun provided you have
others to share in the zombie bashing
[Music]
you